identify 15 over 8 or 15 eights as a
proper or improper fraction so proper
fraction just means that the numerator
is equal or less than or less than or
equal to the denominator so proper
fraction numerator the numerator the
number on top is less than or equal to
the denominator and an improper fraction
in an improper fraction the numerator
the numerator is greater than the
denominator and we see in our example
right here our numerator is greater than
our denominator so we are dealing with
we are dealing with an improper fraction
now a more interesting question is what
does 15 8 even represent so let's think
about that a little bit let me we saw in
the last couple of videos that the
denominator tells you essentially how
many slices of pie there are I guess is
one way to think about it so let me draw
let me draw something with 8 let me
divide something in maybe we could view
this as a square pizza or square pie of
some kind so let's say that's the entire
pie I'm dividing it into well let's be
dividing it into 2 that would divide it
into 4 and then to divide it into 8 I'd
be just like that so this would be up
one whole pie now what does one of these
boxes represent what does that box right
there represent well we've seen this is
one of the eight total pieces of pie so
this represents this represents 1/8 now
if I were to shade in in blue
let's inch and blue I would shade in
this box and that box right there and I
were to say what fraction of my pie is
shaded in blue well you'd say I have two
boxes shaded in blue one two I have two
boxes shaded in blue out of a total of
eight boxes out of a total of eight
boxes this is these two right here are
two eight to eight of the entire pie
or another way to think about it another
way to think about it this is equal to
two of these pieces right so you could
say this is also equal to two times 1/8
because each of these boxes each of
these boxes right here is 1/8 we saw
that right there it is one of the total
8 pieces and so this 2 of the 8 that's
really just two of these 18.1 eight
boxes now if everything I've just said
makes sense let's think about what 15
eights mean so if you imagine these
boxes like that let's try to do 15
eights so if you were to draw so that's
1/8 right there I'm gonna do the same
size of these boxes and let me copy and
paste this so let me copy and then let
me paste so then that's that would be
two eights
let me do 3/8 and then four we're gonna
go all the way up to 15 hope it doesn't
bore you that is 5 6 7 8 and now we've
made a whole pie but we're only at 8 we
have to get this 15 so then we let's
keep going so then we're gonna start
another pie so it's 1 2 3 so so far how
many you have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 and 15
so what if I just drawn here with all
these these pink with all of these pink
squares each of these is 1/8 each of
these boxes is 1/8 of a pie I guess
that's how you could think about it this
is 1/8 and I've just drawn 15 times 1/8
so all of these combined all of these
combined are 15 times 1/8 or we could
say that this is also equal to if we
just use the logic we did before 15 over
8
now how many pies do I have here well
these first eight of the 15
this right here this right here that is
8 out of 8 or 8 1 8 and that's equal to
1 whole pie
so this right here is equal to 1 that
right there is equal to 1 and what do we
have over here we have one whole pie 8
out of 8 of pieces of a potential pie or
8 out of 8 1 eighths of a pie I guess
you could call it and then over here we
have 7/8 of a pie right you can imagine
a whole pie would would it involve
another grid right there
would involve one more over here but
this is 7 out of the 8 so this right
here let me do this in another color
this piece right here represents 7 7
times 1 8 or 7 8 so if you were to say
what 15 over 8 kind of represents it
represents one whole pie and then 7/8 of
another pie and you can even write that
down as a mixed number and it's a mixed
number because it has a whole number and
a fraction so this is equal to one whole
pie this is equal to one whole pie right
there and 7/8 of another pie and 7/8 of
another pie and that's all it represents
what do you think about what 15 eights
means now I had to draw it out like this
but a quick way you can do to solve this
is to divide 8 into 15 so if you were to
take let me do this with new colors so
if you were to take it 8 right there you
divide 8 into you divide 8 into 15 you
divide 8 into 15 you see that it's equal
to well 8 goes into 15 one time because
2 times 8 is 16 so that's too big so 1
times 8 is 8
you subtract 15 minus 8 is 7 is 7 so to
get one in 7/8 this one right here so
you get one whole 8 in there if you have
15 eights you get a whole 8 in there and
then you have 7 left over but these are
7/8 so that's where that 7/8 come from
you have to write the remainder over 8
hopefully you found that helpful